[Music]
hello how are you greetings to him and
jaramillo with their brief informative
today Monday November 30 as
of today there are changes in the
test site of the university the
test center of a uvi moves from the
showman semak to the  sean footer building
located southeast of the corner of
flamengo and university streets is on
the drive hours of operation
remain the same from 8 to 4 pm and is
open from sunday to thursday it is
recommended that you make an appointment you can
find a complete list  For other
sites to get tested for
coronavirus on
the southern nevada health district
website also on the
health sector website you will find more
sites to get tested in the
valley in the city of boulder city
a testing center was opened in the
aubert sense supermarket and it is
open in the morning on wednesday from
6 to 9 in the morning and in the afternoon from 3
in the afternoon to 6 in the afternoon  they do not require an
appointment while in the city of jaén
there is another new testing site that has
opened in the center for seniors
heritage park shin and faster and from 8 in the
morning until noon on fridays
and if you avoided shopping in
person during  This past
holiday weekend, today is Cyber ​​Monday, the
day when offers abound on
Internet sites, according to the
Nevada Retail Association, it
is anticipated that about 75
percent of consumers in the state
will make their purchases during this day.  This
figure is 10 percent more than last year,
so some
local businesses are already preparing, such as
Sandwich Coffee and Mother Sep
Coffee are offering
Christmas sales today
with fewer people doing their
Christmas shopping in stores on
postal service is also anticipating
more mailings this year here are some of the
important dates to know
for your mailings  arrive on time to
send holiday gifts to military or
people in prisons the
packages must be sent before December 11
if you plan to send your
gifts by priority you must send it
before December 19 while
for the gifts to arrive by express delivery they
must  send them before
december 23rd now we move on with your
weather forecast there will be sun and clouds
for today with a high
approaching 64 degrees
breezes and more sun expected by the middle of the
week have a nice day toxo and
salt and  jaramillo and this was his brief
informative edition in Spanish
[Music]